Báo cáo sư bộ về vụ tay nặng May-Buy Bây Bộ in Bây Tám Bây Dreamliner của hãng Hà Không Air Indie,
các đề mù tháng khiến hai chân sau mừng người thiệt mạnh đã được cuộc điều tra tay nặng
hẳng hộ nộ cộng vô phần hôm nay. Báo cáo tiếp lộ rằng May-Bây nặng mất lực này
chỉ vài dây sau khi cất cảnh từ Ambea Đ Quận độ Nhi Lan đình Anh.
Zó 2 công tất ngắt nhìn liệu Vô Tình, Mì Khi Quật, Gần như Đồng Thời.
Báo cáo như gió trong mạnh hiếm buông lái có tiến một trong 2 phía công hình vì còn lại tại sao lại nát nhiều liệu.
Phía công kia chả lời rằng anh ta không làm điều đó.
Các công tắc sau đó được chuyển cho lại bị chi trải này trước khi tiến hiệu các kíu May-Buy được phát đi.
Đó là một công tắc, mẹ là bạn nhất công tắc lên dối dí trên nó và việc dí trên nó không về dây dạng.
Phải là một thành động có chuyện mới có thể dí chuyển được công tắc.
Thế ngành từ các mirant lình xâm nhận lộ cư đã mất điện này sau khi May-Buy dời đừng bằng.
May-Buy bắt đường mất độ cao trước khi vượt qua tình dạo bao quen xin bay.
Báo cáo xú bộ ở đây làm 3po một xu xuy đoán.
Dạ đây có thể thấy rằng không có hình vì phá quạ.
Không còn nhép bình như liệu, không có lúc cạnh tắn và cũng không có bình đi giị đến quan đến bảo chiếm May-Buy.
Thả hả không ấy được sân dận đại nhận được nào cao xu bộ dài mới làm trang.
Và cho biết hẳng sẽ tiếp tục hấp tắc tàn dịt với cuộc điều tra tay nạn hàng không ở n度 và các thứ quan chức năng khác.